ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen alles
wird teurer vor allem Lebensmittel
allein im Mai sind die Preise extrem
gestiegen und heute warnt der
Landwirtschaftsminister das ist erst der
Anfang wie können wir uns gesundes Essen
noch leisten und wie können wir
gleichzeitig dafür sorgen dass es der
Umwelt und den Tieren dabei besser geht
das ist die Frage die wir uns heute
stellen wir freuen uns auf Ihre und eure
Fragen und Kommentare wie immer in die
Kommentare oder per Mail an ZDF
heute-live@zdf.de hier unten
eingeblendet wenn ihr und sie die heute
App nutzen und nutzt wir sprechen
darüber mit dem Generalsekretär des
Deutschen Bauernverbandes Bernhard
grüßgen und lasse van Aken
landwirtschaftsexperte von Greenpeace
schönen guten Abend an sie beide schön
dass Sie dabei sind und bevor wir
diskutieren auch darüber woran es liegt
und was man tun kann zeigt Nina
niedergal wie sehr die Präsident
tatsächlich gestiegen sind
so stark sind die Erzeugerpreise noch
nie gestiegen laut Statistischem
Bundesamt waren landwirtschaftliche
Produkte im April um 39,9 Prozent teurer
als im Vorjahr bei tierischen
Erzeugnissen also zum Beispiel Eiern
Milch und Fleisch betrug der Anstieg
34,7 Prozent bei pflanzlichen
Erzeugnissen
45,7 die Getreidepreise sind sogar um
77,6 Prozent angestiegen
einen großen Unterschied macht es häufig
ob man bio- oder konventionell einkauft
ein Beispiel bei einer großen
Supermarktkette kostet der Liter Milch
84 Cent Biomilch 1,15 Euro Eisbergsalat
aus konventionellem Anbau 99 Cent im
Vergleich zu Bio
2,79€. bei Rinderhackfleisch hält sich
die Differenz in Grenzen 1596 für ein
Kilo im Vergleich zu Bio 1748 beim
Hähnchenbrustfilet müssen
VerbraucherInnen für du dafür deutlich
tiefer in die Tasche greifen ein Kilo
aus konventioneller Haltung kostet
12,71€
mehr als das Doppelte
[Musik]
hat der Bauantrag in Lübeck begonnen die
Preise sind gestiegen wie sehr haben wir
gerade gesehen viele Gründe sind bekannt
was sind denn die Antworten der
Bäuerinnen und Bauern was kann man gegen
die steigenden Preise tun
ja guten Abend erstmal und die Antwort
ist natürlich nicht ganz einfach was
kann man tun wir haben ja mehrere
Ursachen wir hatten erstmal auch vor dem
ukrainekrieg einen Nachholbedarf in
Sachen Preise Lebensmittel sind in
Deutschland ja immer sehr günstig
gewesen das ist traditionell so und wir
sind damit mit dieser Preispolitik an
die Grenzen gestoßen und jetzt ist der
Krieg dazu gekommen und hat insbesondere
dazu geführt dass die auch die
Betriebsmittel der Landwirtschaft enorm
im Preis gestiegen sind zum Teil sich
verdreifacht vervierfacht haben und
damit müssen wir jetzt umgehen das heißt
dass ein Teil dieser Preiserhöhungen die
wir jetzt sehen und die wir bis zum
Herbst noch sehen werden dass die
bleiben werden dass die noch mal
dauerhaft sind weil natürlich auch die
Kosten der Landwirtschaft gestiegen sind
genauso wie die Kosten auch in der
gesamten Kette gestiegen sind was können
wir dann noch tun um das einzugrenzen
für uns ist natürlich auch wichtig aus
Sicht der Landwirte
Ladenpreise sind das eine Erzeugerpreise
sind aber die Währung der sich die
Landwirte orientieren müssen und hier
gibt es natürlich noch einen größeren
Unterschied denn sie haben gerade die
Statistik der Erzeugerpreise
zitiert das ist noch nicht das was wir
an der Ladentheke sehen also hier ist
auch noch ein bisschen Luft nach oben
ich möchte gerne was aufgreifen was ihr
Präsident Joachim rugwet heute gesagt
hat mit Blick auf die weltweite
getreidekrise er erwartet zusätzliche
Flächen für den Getreideanbau nutzen zu
können er sagt so könnten mit einer
vorübergehenden Nutzung zusätzlicher
Flächen 1,4 Millionen Tonnen Weizen mehr
erzeugt werden dass es eine der
Möglichkeiten eine der Antworten um auf
ein Problem dieser Krise reagieren zu
können
unterstützen Sie diese Forderung wie
begründen Sie die
ja absolut weil das ist natürlich ein
Beitrag den wir ad hoc und relativ
kurzfristig leisten können aber sie
sehen an den Zahlen das ist natürlich
nur eine kleine Schraube wir müssen noch
mehr tun und wir müssen vor allen Dingen
auch über die Frage Flächenstilllegungen
nun ob das jetzt nur zwei oder drei oder
vier Prozent sind etwas hinausgehen
Europa ist auf dem Weg in eine
selbstverordnete farm to Fox Strategie
die im Wesentlichen darauf beruht dass
wir sag mal landwirtschaftliche
Erzeugung beschränken und das ist
natürlich etwas was in diesen Tagen das
absolut falsche Signal ist hier müssen
wir Umsteuern und müssen im Grunde für
eine Erzeugung die effizient ist die mit
wenig Ressourcen auskommt die mit wenig
Fläche auskommt ja Rückenwind erzeugen
und müssen die Bremsen lockern denn
Europa ist unter dem Strich wenn Sie
alle Produktgruppen zusammen nehmen
immer noch ein Netto Importeur von
Lebensmittel aller Art das würde ich
gerne Herrn van Aken dazu holen das ist
ja quasi die Überschrift brachen sind
Bremsen also Grünflächen sind für
Landwirte nicht nutzbar in dem Sinne wie
sie die Landwirte gerne nutzen würden
Sie Herr grüßen das gerade genannt hat
er von Aken was ist ihre Antwort darauf
Entschuldigung
falls ich sie gerade falsch
interpretiert haben sie dürfen gleich
gerne noch mal reagieren dass das möchte
ich natürlich nicht aber lassen Sie
Herrn von Haken gerade seinen Punkt zum
Thema zum Thema gründlichen Nutzung
machen ich denke wie Herr Christen das
gesagt hat die brachen machen nur einen
marginalen Teil aus wir reden hier von
ca 200.000 Hektar wie Herr Christen vor
ein zwei Monaten in der ARD gesagt hat
und wie viel Weizen können wir dann
darauf überhaupt anbauen das ist sehr
wenig und vor allem wann kommt dieser
reizen wenn es darum geht ihr schnell zu
reagieren muss man sich doch angucken wo
geht der Weiz eigentlich hin den wir in
Deutschland ernten
sie man hat Millionen Tonnen in
Deutschland geernteter Weizen geht zum
Beispiel jedes Jahr in den Futtertrog
damit wir eine günstige Bratwurst auf
dem Grill legen kann knapp eine Million
Tonnen Getreide Weizen meine ich geht in
die produzierung von in die Produktion
von Bio Sprit also da muss man sich
überlegen wie nutzen wir diesen Weizen
den wir haben und danach kann man dann
gucken Wie werden wir in Zukunft
Pflanzen die wir essen anbauen und ich
denke es ist fatal so zu argumentieren
dass man sagt wir haben jetzt eine Krise
deswegen müssen wir alle Umweltstandard
Schleifen nein wir werden in Zukunft
hier öfter Krisen haben wir haben die
Klimakrise wir haben ein dramatischen
Verlust der abendvielfalt und dann
müssen wir uns jetzt für warnen und
jetzt die Umweltstandard zu schleifen
die hier die Landwirtschaft nachhaltiger
machen wollen die er dafür sorgen dass
wir auch in Zukunft ein fruchtbaren
Boden haben in Deutschland und eben
diese Selbstversorgung sichern können
dass halte ich für verteilen bitte
ja zwei Punkte dazu einmal der von Arcan
es ist natürlich immer einfach mit
solchen Abziehbildern zu arbeiten aber
andersrum betrachtet von dem was
Nutztiere in Deutschland fressen sind 6%
backfähiger Weizen also hier müssen wir
auch die Größenordnung mal richtig sehen
und Landwirtschaft ist immer ein
vielfältiges System es gibt dort nie nur
Weizen oder nur nachwachsende Rohstoffe
oder nur Futtermittel es gibt immer
einen Mix und wichtig ist dabei dass wir
Kaskaden nutzen dass wir zum Beispiel
aus Raps Speiseöl Biodiesel machen und
aus dem dem was übrig bleibt dem Raps
Kuchen über die Tierhaltung veredeln wir
haben 5 Millionen Hektar Grünland in
Deutschland dass wir nur über die Tiere
effektiv nutzen können und daraus
Lebensmittel erzeugen können das muss
man eben sehen und ich will noch mal was
sagen zum Thema
brachen und Rolle rückwärts ich habe
leider nicht gesagt und ich lass mich
hier auch ungern falsch zitieren dass
wir jetzt zurückgehen wollen in die
erzeugungsschlacht der 70er 80er Jahre
wir müssen beides tun wir müssen
natürlich etwas tun für Artenvielfalt in
der Agrarlandschaft das tun wir auch das
können wir auch das können wir aber auch
auf Flächen die wir noch in einer
kombinationsnutzung unterbringen können
also die Gleichung ist nicht so
wie das jetzt rüberkam dass wenn wir
hier diese
im Agrar der politischen Fachjargon
unproduktiven Flächen wenn wir die jetzt
einfach umwidmen dann sind nicht die
brachen verschwunden das sind noch
andere ökologische Oberflächen
entschuldigen sie entschuldigen sie
bevor ich ich würde gerne gleich noch
ein bisschen mehr auch auf den
preisaspekt kommen weil das was ist was
natürlich viele Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer sehr sehr umtreibt aber ich
würde gerne eine Frage an Sie beide mit
in diesen Komplex mit rein nehmen weil
er dazu passt Daniel Wolf fragt über
Youtube kann man bei effizienterer
Landwirtschaft dann landwirtschaftliche
Flächen der Natur zurückgeben wer von
ihnen möchte darauf antworten denn
Christen hat vollkommen recht
Landwirtschaft ist ein komplexes System
und ich habe ja auch nicht gesagt dass
wir nicht essbare Biomasse jetzt nicht
mehr verfüttern dürfen es geht darum
dass wir Lebensmittel Weizen den wir
essen können selber essen und die
Pflanzen Rest an Tiere verfüttern darum
geht es dass wir auch wenn siebeneinhalb
Millionen von Weizen die wir in
Deutschland ernten verfüttern statt den
Menschen zur Verfügung zu stellen die ja
unter Hunger bleiben ich glaube was
wirklich wichtig ist wir gucken uns die
Nutzung an und wenn wir weniger Fleisch
Milchprodukte konsumieren würden und
wenn wir aufhören würden
lebensmittelfähigen Weizen in Tank zu
verbrennen dann haben wir ganz viel
freie Fläche die können wir
renaturisieren oder wir können darauf
Lebensmittel die wir dann auch essen
anbauen und ich glaube das ist
entscheidend und der größten ich muss ja
auch korrigieren wir haben ungefähr 80
Prozent der Weizenernte in Deutschland
die backfähig ist ich weiß nicht wie sie
auf diese sechs Prozent kommen ich bin
bei der Uni Hohenheim wie diese Zahlen
veröffentlicht und dazu muss man ja auch
sagen wenn ich Hunger habe dann esse ich
auch Weizen den vielleicht der deutsche
Konsument beim Bäcker nicht essen würde
in Form eines Brötchen also da wir reden
hier von Menschen die Hunger leiden und
ich finde es ethisch sehr fragwürdig bis
verwerflich hier zu sagen der Weizen ist
nicht so gut deswegen verfüttern wir den
lieber für eine billige Wurst auf dem
Grill dann würde ich an der Stelle
tatsächlich gerne zu der Preisfrage
kommen Natalia n fragte über YouTube wo
soll die Preisspirale denn noch
hinführen das ist das ist der zentrale
Punkt den den viele Verbraucherinnen und
Verbraucher sich stellen und das
Paradoxe ist ja Herr grüßgen dass der
Bauernverband schon seit Jahren höhere
Lebensmittelpreise fordert sie haben das
eingangs auch gesagt jetzt sind die
höheren Preise da aber die Bauern haben
nichts davon
zwei Dinge einmal will ich noch auf die
Frage von Herrn Wolf zurückkommen weil
die ist nämlich elementar wichtig was
machen wir mit dieser Fläche können wir
überhaupt Fläche freisetzen und da
sitzen wir in Deutschland ziemlich in
der Klemme wir haben seit den 90er
Jahren anderthalb Millionen Hektar
landwirtschaftliche Nutzfläche verloren
sie sind versiegelt worden sie sind für
Infrastrukturprojekte für Gewerbegebiete
für Wohnbebauung für Straßen und für
Infrastrukturprojekte sozusagen sehr
sorglos verbraucht worden und das sind
ungefähr 10% unserer Ackerfläche und
dieser Prozess geht weiter wir verlieren
jeden Tag immer noch
ungefähr 50 Hektar und solange dieser
Prozess so weitergeht kann man nicht
einfach sagen na dann hören wir halt auf
mit dem Fleisch essen und alles wird gut
das ist eine sehr simple und eine
Entschuldigung auch einfältige Gesicht
weil Tierhaltung weil ja weil weil
Tierhaltung ohne eine gute Tierhaltung
mögen sie den Ackerbau auch nicht
wirklich in Gang und es gehört einfach
mit zu einer guten Kreislaufwirtschaft
das Tierhaltung stattfindet aber jetzt
noch mal zu den Preisen das war ja die
zweite Frage also vielleicht mal eine
Größenordnung wenn ich das
über den breiten Daumen mal
zusammenrechne was Landwirtschaft in vor
2020 jährlich ausgegeben hat für Energie
das ein bisschen wesentlichen Diesel das
sind Kraftstoffe für die mechanische
Arbeit die eben im
ökologischen Landbau im klassischen
Landbau aufzuwenden ist 100 Liter pro
Hektar und dann noch das Thema
Düngemittel dazu nehme dann ist das eine
Größenordnung von ungefähr fünf bis
sechs Milliarden Euro das hat sich jetzt
dramatisch verteuert und wir haben einen
Preissprung wenn ich das auf
Landwirtschaft in Deutschland hochrechne
das was wir jetzt an an
Preissteigerungen auf der
betriebsmittelseite gesehen habe dann
ist das mehr auf die Hälfte dessen was
Landwirtschaft insgesamt für pflanzliche
Produkte an Verkaufserlösen hat
andersrum formuliert nur um das Thema
Energie und Düngemittel aufzufangen im
Preis müssen sich die Preise die
Erzeugerpreise für pflanzliche
Erzeugnisse um um etwa 60 bis 70 Prozent
erhöhen dann haben wir diese
Kostensteigerung kompensiert das muss
man eben sehen und wir glauben glaube
ich alle nicht dass sich die Märkte für
Energie und Düngemittel ist ja im Grunde
auch nichts anderes als ein Ausdruck für
Energiekosten dass die sich so
kurzfristig normalisieren werden und so
schwierig das für Verbraucher ist so
sehr sind wir
ja so sehr müssen wir doch auch uns
eingestehen dass das ein Stück weit
bleiben wird und wenn ich das noch
ergänzen darf wir waren gerade bei der
Ethik wenn ich sehe dass
klar das Russland mit dem geklauten
Getreide aus der Ukraine in Afrika
herumläuft und sich dort versucht
Sympathien zu kaufen dann finde ich das
auch nicht ethisch und dann wird mir
auch schlecht und
das ist etwas was ich auch der
Preisdiskussion entzieht und das ist
auch eine ethische Verpflichtung dass
wir dem etwas entgegensetzen und auch
ein Stück weit hier
die Produktion die Erzeugung die wir
hier in Europa auf einem gunststandort
machen können auch so weiter stattfinden
lassen genau ich bin ganz bei Ihnen wenn
wir sagen wir müssen dem etwas
entgegensetzen aber wir helfen noch den
Menschen in den Krise Regionen und auch
dem world-free-programm der UNO nicht
die schon die lebensmittelration senken
musste weil die Preise so hoch waren wir
helfen noch diesen Akteuren nicht wenn
wir den Weizen den wir haben schlecht
einsetzen zum Beispiel indem wir eben
das für die Bio spritproduktion
einsetzen oder eben für die
Futtermittelproduktion und auch noch mal
um auf die Fläche zurückzukommen stellen
Sie sich mal die Deutsch Deutschland vor
die Hälfte davon wird ungefähr
landwirtschaftlich genutzt halb
Deutschland und davon wiederum 70%
werden verwendet um Tiere zu ernähren 70
Prozent ich sage Ihnen wir wollen
überhaupt nicht die Tierhaltung
abschaffen das möchte ich hier keiner
und das möchte Greenpeace auch nicht
aber was doch klar ist dass wir viel zu
viele Tiere haben das kommt mit diversen
Problemen wir haben einen dramatischen
Verlust der Artenvielfalt in Deutschland
die Klimakrise wir haben eine
Grundwasserbelastung und jetzt haben wir
noch diese Hungerkrise und da frage ich
natürlich mich natürlich schon müssen
wir dann ewig so weitermachen können wir
jetzt nicht gucken wie schaffen wir das
dass wir ein Abbau der Tierzahlen haben
auch dass die Landwirte und
LandwirtInnen mehr verdienen denn da bin
ich auch ganz bei Herr Krusten es kann
nicht sein dass wir jedes Jahr drei 4000
Betriebe verlieren und zwar für immer
wären sich andere Akteure entlang der
Lieferkette wahrscheinlich
eine gute ein gutes Geschäft machen also
da bin ich wie gesagt bei ihnen wir
müssen gucken dass wir die Landwirte und
LandwirtInnen in Deutschland halten mit
guten Preis und das bedeutet eben leider
auch dass die Menschen etwas mehr
einfach ausgeben müssen ich möchte aber
noch mal einen Aspekt ins Spiel bringen
und zwar haben wir untersuchen lassen
vom Ökoinstitut was wäre denn der Effekt
wenn wir die Mehrwertsteuer für Obst und
Gemüse auf 0% senken würden das darf man
laut EU seit einigen Monaten aber
gleichzeitig die Mehrwertsteuer für
Fleisch und Milchprodukte anpassen auf
19 Prozent das hat zur Folge dass die
Menschen etwas weniger Fleisch essen
etwa 10% weniger und mehr Obst und
Gemüse was ja auch aus gesundheitlichen
Aspekten sehr sehr lobenswert wäre und
am Ende des Tages hat jeder Konsument
drei am Ende des Jahres hat jeder
Konsument 30 Euro mehr in der Tasche
weil eben weniger Fleisch konsumiert
würde also das sind doch so
Lösungsansätze über die man diskutieren
könnte die meine Spiel bringen könnte um
eben mehrere Fliegen mit einer Klappe zu
schlagen genau diese Frage oder diese
Anregung hat größten Sekunde geben Sie
mir die Chance eine Zuschauerin mit ins
Boot zu nehmen die nämlich genau diesen
Hinweis gegeben hat Tim Meier hat
angeregt meine Frage braucht es nicht
wirklich eine Steuerbefreiung für Obst
Gemüse und Hülsen exotische Früchte
meinetwegen ausgenommen Herr Christkind
was spricht denn dagegen
wir sagen das Lebensmittel grundsätzlich
niedrig besteuert werden sollten weil
sie eben halt Lebensmittel sind und
ich weiß nicht wie das mit solchen
Lenkung steuern ist wir sehen ja gerade
beim Tankrabatt dass das nicht so
einfach funktioniert und dass diese
Lenkungseffekte auch nicht da sind und
deshalb muss man da nicht ansetzen zum
Thema strukturwandeln
dass dass die Wissenschaft festgestellt
hat dass der Tankrabatt sehr wohl was
gebracht hat haben wir heute morgen vom
ifo-Institut gehört zum Thema Lenkung
genau die Wissenschaft hat festgestellt
und das kann man ja jeden Tag an der
Zapfsäule sehen was soll ich dazu noch
sagen
ich glaube die Lebenserfahrung der
meisten Zuschauer ist definitiv eine
andere
und ich möchte dann noch etwas zum Thema
Tierhaltung sagen sehen Sie mir das
nachher von AK aber das ist mir alles
auch ein bisschen zu pauschal weil wir
haben natürlich bei den 70 Prozent ich
weiß nicht ob man das so rechnen darf
eine ganze Reihe von Flächen die sich
nicht anders nutzen lassen die sozusagen
nur über die Tierhaltung genutzt werden
können und das mit den sechs Prozent das
passt schon zusammen weil wir
produzieren in Deutschland ja glaube ich
etwas über 20 Millionen Tonnen Weizen 22
Millionen Tonnen und wenn ich dann die
futtermittelmenge die in Deutschland
[Musik]
das sind das sind ungefähr 200 Millionen
Tonnen da muss man auch sehen ob man da
richtig voneinander ist aber ein ganz
wichtiger Punkt ist noch
warum findet dieser Strukturwandel
findet dieses Höfe sterben statt oder
warum hat es stattgefunden in den
letzten Jahren und warum wir auch
befürchten dass es weitergeht die
Ursache ist ja nicht
dass die Agrarpolitik so oder so
herumtig sondern die Ursache ist ein
schlichtweg von wirtschaftlicher Druck
das ist das Resultat einer
vorschreitende Konzentration die vor und
nachgelagerten Bereich und es ist eine
ein Ergebnis des europäischen
Wettbewerbs wir haben einen gemeinsamen
Markt aber wir haben nicht gemeinsame
Regeln und
Landwirtschaft in Deutschland hat sich
in den letzten 10-15 Jahren
na wie soll ich sagen einer immer
steigenden Regelungsdichte erfreuen
dürfen Regeln die natürlich zu hohen
Kosten führen die ein großer Betrieb
leichter tragen kann als ein kleiner
Betrieb und
das sehen wir jetzt zum Beispiel in der
Tierhaltung und deshalb ist das ein
bisschen unehrlich wenn man auf der
einen Seite ständig höhere Auflagen
erfordert und politisch installiert und
sich auf der anderen Seite beklagt
darüber dass die Anzahl der Betriebe
abnimmt
darf ich ganz kurz einhaken denn diese
Argumente des Bauernverbandes die kennen
wir in der Tat schon seit sehr langer
Zeit natürlich sind Sie berechtigt aber
wir hören sie wiederholt wenn man
versucht das Ganze ein bisschen
konstruktiver zu machen was wäre denn
wenn man sagt man nimmt das viele Geld
aus den Invest aus den Subventionen und
steckt es in mehr Forschung zum Beispiel
wie man nachhaltig wirtschaften kann wie
man
zum Beispiel wie ein User namens
Tortellini fragt mehr Forschung für
künstlich gewachsenes Fleisch fördern
kann um so die Umwelt zu entlasten und
Preise niedrig zu halten es gibt doch so
viele Stellschrauben die man mit dem
vielen Geld machen kann von denen die
Landwirte auch langfristig profitieren
könnten
naja wir sind ja jetzt schon auch mit
dieser
reformrunde der Agrarpolitik die jetzt
gerade
produktiv geht sind wir ja schon so weit
dass wir ungefähr
zwei Drittel der Mitte ich sage das
jetzt über den breiten Daumen in einer
Zweckbindung für Leistungen in Umwelt
Klima Artenschutz Junglandwirte
Förderung Förderung des ländlichen Raums
Förderung des Ökolandbaus eben in Teilen
der ersten Säule der zweiten Säule haben
dieser Prozess wird weitergehen deshalb
ist der Fundus des Geldes dass man
ja dort vermutet und dass man einfach so
umwidmen kann gar nicht so groß ich
glaube dass wir schon eine gute
Forschungslandschaft haben
Forschungsförderung ist immer richtig es
ist immer gut aber mit dem
retortenfleisch sind wir zum Beispiel
eben im Moment noch nicht nachhaltig
unterwegs weil
es wird ja immer so getan als würden
diese Protein Alternativen vom Himmel
fallen aber die brauchen natürlich auch
Energie die brauchen Rohstoffe und
solange wir sozusagen beim kunstfleisch
noch darüber reden dass solche
Zellkulturen mit dem
kälberblut Serum
ernährt werden müssen dann sind wir von
der Nachhaltigkeit weit weit weit
entfernt und es ist kein clean meet
sondern es ist ganz schön dreckig ich
möchte gerne gleich noch mal über das
internationale
Gleichgewicht gucken wer wie viel darauf
gucken wer wie viel ausgibt dabei Herr
von Akne ich möchte ihn gern noch die
Gelegenheit geben auf ein Christkind zu
antworten ja ich finde es bemerkenswert
wir Christen sich jetzt hier als
Vorkämpfer für kleine Betriebe darstellt
also bei dieser Reform der EU
Agrarpolitik wo es ja um 6 Milliarden
Euro jährlich geht hat der Bauernverband
verhindert dass große Betriebe ein
Deckel bekommen also dass da
Maximalbetrag versteht was umgekehrt
bedeutet kleinere Betriebe und weitere
Betriebe kommen mehr und das sind doch
die bäuerlichen Betriebe die wir
brauchen in Deutschland also das finde
ich jetzt schon ziemlich bemerkenswert
und was ich eben auch schade finde ist
dass der Christkind sich eher darauf
konzentriert bestehende Umweltstandards
zurückzudrehen während wir hier eine
Krise haben die eigentlich nur noch mal
bestärkt dass wir doch gucken müssen wie
können wir in Zukunft die Menschen auf
dieser Welt ernähren nicht indem wir
noch quasi mit dem Besen die letzte Ecke
aushingen und auf ganz schlechten
Standort noch ein bisschen Weizen
rausquetschen sondern indem wir uns
angucken wie wird dieser Weizen
eingesetzt und dann können zum Beispiel
Alternativen Fleisch oder Milch
Alternativen eine Lösung sein dieses
Labor miet was sie die das Labor Fleisch
was Sie angesprochen haben da kann ich
gar nicht so viel zu sagen da bin ich
ganz bei Herr Christel da muss man
erstmal gucken aber es gibt ja ganz
viele andere Alternativen und ich finde
es eher ein bisschen destruktiv und wir
versuchen jetzt eben Lösungen zu finden
und ich glaube
das weiß auch er ist in mir der jetzt
ganz konkret versucht Maßnahmen zu
ergreifen wie wir Weizen aus der Ukraine
rauskriegen und dann müssen wir eben
gucken was machen wir damit und das darf
ihm nicht im futtertrock landen dann
schauen wir uns mal an wie viel die
Deutschen im europaweiten Vergleich
Entschuldigung
weil das ist ja ich bin ganz kurz also
er von argen ich weiß die dass sie
aktivistische Logik manchmal auch nicht
ganz linear ist und wenn Sie hier solche
Dinge rauskramen und den Bauernverband
zuschreiben dann empfehle ich Ihnen die
Lektüre des Abschlussbericht ist der
Zukunftskommission Landwirtschaft in der
der Weg der GAP vorgezeichnet ist mit
Unterstützung und Mitarbeiter des
Deutschen Bauernverbandes und dort steht
etwas ganz anderes und vielleicht ist
der eine oder andere interessierte Hörer
auch dazu bereit sich diese zwei Seiten
zum Thema GAP mal anzuschauen und da
finde ich den Vorwurf mal ganz
vorsichtig aus oder nicht bestätigen
Jahreszahl ab wann sie das denn machen
wollen ich glaube es war 2034 wir haben
heute 2022 und es geht um die GAP die
nächstes Jahr statt der nächsten im
Laufe im Laufe der nächsten beiden
Planungsperioden und sie wissen das auch
merken dass der Zug schon dass der dass
der Zug schon rollt und bevor die beiden
Herren sich jetzt hier in Jahreszahlen
und in und in Prozentzahlen
verstreiten möchte ich an der Sterne
Stelle gerne unterbrechen und
tatsächlich den Blick weiten darauf
wieder zu den Verbraucherinnen und
Verbrauchern und zu dem was Haushalte
ausgeben und ausgeben müssen schauen wir
mal Deutschland im europäischen
Vergleich
in Osteuropa geben die Menschen
prozentual am meisten für Lebensmittel
aus spitzenreiter ist Rumänien wo
28,3% der Konsumausgaben auf
Lebensmittel entfallen der
EU-Durchschnitt liegt bei 15,9 die
Deutschen geben prozentual mit am
wenigsten aus mit
11,1%. dahinter liegen nur die
Luxemburger und die Iren mit 10,8%
. ja auch ein Usernamens Alexander
Angelopoulos merkt an Lebensmittel in
Deutschland sind im Verhältnis zum
Einkommen nach wie vor sehr günstig Herr
von Aken was ist ihre Position dazu oder
ihre Folgerung ja ich denke man hat es
gesehen und
ich ich glaube
es ist auch eine soziale Frage also man
kann jetzt nicht einfach sagen die
Preise müssen hoch und ich habe ja
vorhin den Vorschlag erwähnt wie man
eine Entlassung für die Bürger und
Bürgerinnen darstellen kann mit einer
Reform der Mehrwertsteuer wo Fondant
gleichzeitig auch Klima und
Biodiversität profitieren ich würde
gerne auch noch mal das Auge darauf
lenken auf die Region wo 80 90 Prozent
des Einkommens für Lebensmittel
ausgegeben werden weil das geht mir
jetzt nicht auf den aus dem Kopf im
Rahmen dieser Krise dass da Leute
hungern und und ich finde diese
Diskussion wichtig und richtig über die
hohen Preise in Deutschland aber solange
wir Weizen im Tank verbrennen und Weizen
verfüttern in einem riesigen Ausmaß ist
Hungerkrise die immer schlimmer wird
auch unsere Krise
also er von einem fragen Sie die
agrarökonomen wie viel sich das
Preisniveau für Lebensmittel verändert
wenn man diese kombinationsnutzung
Bioenergie und die Kombination zum
Tierhaltung wegfallen lässt ich glaube
da wird sich nicht viel bewegen weil
gerade beim Thema Getreide und
Getreideprodukte sind wir ja doch in der
Situation dass ich glaube nur vier oder
fünf Prozent des Preises den der
Verbraucher an der Theke für Brot und
Backwaren bezahlt auf das Getreide
entfällt aber es ist tatsächlich
ein sehr tiefgreifendes Problem 11
Prozent das natürlich ein relativer Wert
man muss da die absoluten Zahlen daneben
setzen aber das ist ganz schön wenig und
das ist viel zu wenig und das heißt dass
wir hier in einer Volkswirtschaft
unterwegs sind der auch in der große
Teile der verbraucherschaft durchaus
auch vielleicht ein Prozent
Verkehr ausgeben können und auch
ausgeben wollen das muss man ja auch mal
sehen wir führen wir haben vor dem 24
Februar diesen Jahres eine Diskussion
darüber geführt
das Lebensmittel nachhaltig erzeugt
werden können und haben dort in ganz
ganz vielen Umfragen insbesondere bei
tierischen Lebensmittel ein ganz klarer
Bereitschaft und den Wunsch von vielen
Verbrauchern gesehen dass sie mehr tun
wollen für höhere Standards dass sie
also auch diese diese höheren Standards
honorieren wollen und das sollten wir
auch jetzt nicht über Bord werfen
natürlich gibt es
gibt es auch hier in Nordwesteuropa
Verbraucher bei denen natürlich ein sehr
höherer Anteil als 11 Prozent
des Einkommens für Lebensmittel
ausgegeben wird aber hier muss man auch
deutlich unterscheiden zwischen Europa
und dem Rest der Welt und
ich glaube wir werden Afrika auch nicht
von Europa aus ernähren können indem wir
hier unseren Konsum an tierischen
Lebensmitteln reduzieren Sie wissen
glaube ich alle das auch Landwirtschaft
beispielsweise in Afrika
ein sehr komplexes Geschehen ist
das kann ja auch perspektivisch nicht
die Lösung sein dass wir über World Food
Programm dort die Dinge dahin schaffen
weil unser Lösungsansatz ist eigentlich
die wir brauchen eine starke
Landwirtschaft vor Ort und die Landwirte
dort in diesem Regionen die müssen
die müssen
ich sehe dass es sehr unterschiedlich
unterschiedliche Positionen zum Thema
Afrika gibt auch das würde ich gerne an
der Stelle mal so stehen lassen wie
gesagt auch das ist ein eigenes ein
eigenes Thema ich würde gerne noch mal
unsere Userinnen und User mit reinnehmen
und einfach weil der Chat sehr lebendig
ist und es viele Kommentare und Fragen
gibt ihnen beiden auch noch ein bisschen
zeigen worum es in den Chat steht also
Herbert Fritzmann fragt sagt zum
Beispiel über Youtube wir brauchen
weniger Tiere stattdessen artgerechte
Haltung Erzeugerpreise für
Qualitätsfleisch muss sich erhöhen und
der Mehrpreis den Bauern zugute kommen
eine Position dann schreibt Alex die
über Youtube man sollte die deutschen
Bauern besser vor der Billigkonkurrenz
aus dem Ausland schützen und fördern
Herr Christkind ich nehme an da stimmen
sie voll zu Natalia n fragt über oder
sagt über Youtube wenn die Preise zu
hoch sind und die Produkte nicht
abgekauft werden dann haben die Erzeuger
auch nichts davon das wiederum würde
mich zu meiner Schlussfrage bringen das
können Sie gerne mit einfließen lassen
was sie gerade sagen wollten Herr
Christkind wo geht denn die Reise hin
die Preise werden steigen das hat der
Landwirtschaftsminister gesagt müssen
wir Verbraucher Angst haben dass wir uns
gute Lebensmittel nicht mehr leisten
können und dass ich manche ganz
überspitz gesagt überhaupt keine
Lebensmittel mehr leisten können weil es
einfach viel zu teuer wird
also alle drei Beiträge aus dem
Zuhörerkreis sind absolut richtig kann
man eins zu eins unterschreiben und ich
will noch mal gerade weil die Tiere die
tierischen Lebensmittel hier erwähnt
worden sind dafür eine Lanze brechen
wenn Sie beispielsweise bei dem
Erzeugerpreis für Fleisch 20 oder 30
Cent drauflegen und garantieren dass
dieses Geld 100% beim Landwirt ankommt
dann können Sie direkt drei
Qualitätsstufen beim Tierwohl damit
überspringen und darstellen und das ist
unser Problem
wir haben natürlich im Markt der ist der
ist europäisch halt dominiert wir haben
im Sektor Schwein die spanischen
Kollegen die seit
drei Jahren konsequent aufdrehen ihre
Produktion ohne diese ganzen
Restriktionen die wir so haben über die
Preise in die Märkte eindringen und uns
hier in die Defensive bringen und wenn
wir da Mechanismen entwickeln das so
etwas nicht stattfindet dann können wir
hier auch fahren und wenn wir dann auch
noch an dem Anteil dem
Wertschöpfungsanteil der Landwirte
Arbeiten die die für ihre Produkte
bekommen also den Anteil der an der
Ladentheke dann Richtung Landwirt geht
wenn der größer wird dann müssen wir uns
keine Sorgen machen dass hochwertige
Lebensmittel unbezahlbar werden aber wir
müssen uns damit abfinden dass sie
teurer werden
hier und da zustimmen es ist es ist ein
Problem
wir haben aber auch das muss man so
sagen wir hatten jetzt 16 Jahre cdu/csu
geführte Agrarpolitik die auch dazu
geführt hat wo wir heute stehen der
Umbau der Landwirtschaft wurde immer
wieder
verschleppt und jetzt sind halt die
Landwirte und LandwirtInnen da und haben
das Problem ich denke wo wir hinkommen
müssen ist weniger Export also wir haben
sehr hohen Selbstversorgungsgrad bei
Schweinefleisch und Milchprodukten dass
wir hinkommen wie Herr Christian auch
gesagt hatte dass wir einen höheren
Standard haben dass der auch transparent
ist dafür haben wir bei Greenpeace ja
auch immer gekämpft da hilft diese
Tierwohl Kennzeichnung dass wir dahin
kommen dass die KonsumentInnen erkennen
im Laden das hier ist besseres Fleisch
dafür gebe ich auch etwas mehr aus und
darüber hinaus muss man auch sagen das
ist eine Bewegung die überfällig ist
denn aktuell prüft das
Bundesverfassungsgericht ob denn
überhaupt die Schweinemast so wie wir
sie in Deutschland haben
verfassungskonform ist da wird es Ende
etwas eine Entscheidung geben das heißt
nochmal ist es mehr als überfällig den
Umbau der Tierhaltung voranzutreiben und
das bedeutet weniger Tiere für die die
Landwirte und LandwirtInnen aber mehr
Geld bekommen und das bedeutet
tatsächlich auch im Umkehrschluss die
Preise für Fleisch und Milchprodukte
werden hochgehen ein wenig aber ich sage
auch der Durchschnittskonsument in
Deutschland ist über ein Kilo Fleisch
jede Woche und da sind alle VeganerInnen
und Babys mit eingezählt also wer dann
halt nur nach 800 Gramm ist das ist
immer noch zu viel die Deutsche
Gesellschaft für Ernährung empfiehlt
drei bis maximal 600 Gramm die Woche
also ich glaube ja es wird höhere Preise
geben und wir müssen eben gucken dass
möglichst viel davon bei den Betrieben
ankommt
sagt lasse van arken
landwirtschaftsexperte von Greenpeace
ihnen vielen Dank Herr von Aken und
Bernhard krösgen vom Deutschen
Bauernverband auch vielen herzlichen
Dank und danke auch dass sie sich auf
diese Art der Diskussion eingelassen
haben an zwei verschiedenen Orten vor
Kameras die konnten sich gegenseitig
nicht sehen aber sie haben sehr lebendig
miteinander diskutiert das hat viel
Freude gemacht vielen Dank und auch
Ihnen liebe Userinnen und User vielen
Dank für die rege Beteiligung und die
vielen Fragen vielen Dank und schönen
Abend und bis zum nächsten Mal bei ZDF
heute live